all right
welcome everybody to today's deepak
show pra right
okay we are just moments away
oh i'm muted oh no no i'm kidding we are
just moments away
from congressional hearings on
game stunk reddit wall street bets
dfv robin hood
etc okay in i expect that these are
going to be
very compelling very very compelling so
i'm glad that you're with me and by the
way
just by sheer chance two hours from now
nasa's perseverance mars rover is
scheduled to land
on mars so we may even be here for that
uh and it may even we may even have a
live broadcast from
nars g-n-a-r-s so a lot of different
things going on it's going to be very
very
interesting um and i'm glad you're with
me chaka seki coming in
with a message about ted cruz who says
ted cruz's new mullet and characteristic
slouched posture make him a dead
giveaway at the airport as he was caught
fleeing from work and
antifa yeah i have that right here ted
this guy is unbelievable ted cruz
in the middle of disgusting power
outages
in great part caused by texas
republicans refusing 10 years ago
to winterize primarily nuclear coal and
natural gas plants and also wind
turbines
ted cruz voted no for money for new york
and new jersey in 2012 after hurricane
sandy
demands massive dumps of money from the
federal government
and here he is yesterday going to cancun
ted cruz is part of the political party
that is based in part
on the idea that mexicans are all
desperate to come to the united states
to flee mexico
here is a picture of ted cruz fleeing
the united states
for mexico and uh
i think we have a picture of him here he
is on the plane
this very quickly this is yesterday this
very quickly became a pr fiasco
so uh we figured out that here is cruz
he rebooked himself on a flight back
today
and i guess that i don't know if this is
a joke but
i guess there was a claim that he was
just going for moral support with his
family and was going to come back or
something like that
but he had big luggage like you don't
need that much luggage for
for one day it's all completely nuts
it's all completely nuts
and now ted cruz standing by
wait where was that last image oh this
is my twitter that's weird
um ted cruz standing by for an upgrade
to business class
where did the anyway um so that's what's
going on there
absolutely nutty nutty story with ted
cruz
and the guy's a joke he should resign
he's disgusting etc etc you guys all
know that all right
other super chats people shot out of a
cannon today thanks for the shout out in
yesterday's show says quincy vigil
its sad power outages have turned
political
oh oh [ __ ] no that no wonder yeah quincy
vigil
is a is a meteorologist oh my god now i
make i was like oh yeah quincy right
by chance i came across a a tweet from
quincy vigil
a meteorologist showing that
the places having the power outages are
places that are disproportionately
reliant on fossil fuel energy not wind
turbines
and quincy is here beautiful appreciate
it
uh if you ever need weather climate
science info love to help out beautiful
beautiful i like that all right richard
says gotta
check out a clip from roaring kitty's
youtube he's the guy testifying and he's
electric yeah
i'm looking forward to these hearings
very much so and daniel johnson says our
government is so corrupt they are
probably going to declare wall street
bets is a terrorist organization
and bail robin hood out i'm taking bets
yeah we'll see
we'll see i'm expecting a lot of uh very
very wacky
wacky things big thank you to
that crazy guy nt as well as
dmb 205 tanja lorraine
oh no tangela irene i think is the right
way to parse that
and big thank you to astro lycos
for gifting five subs on twitch
that's seven in total my friends and uh
a real
a real crooked number that we're putting
up on the board
um let's see i have a few other things
to get to
uh i have yeah i have troy york
voicemails yesterday we
allowed the audience to decide whether i
play troy york voicemails or not i guess
we can do that again
i have a poll question ready here should
i play troy york voicemails today
um i'm gonna paste it a few times in
twitch
i'm going by the audience voting okay so
people don't don't just vote
don't complain just vote now i'm pasting
it here
in a youtube and you can start voting
right now
and then that will be how we decide
whether or not to play
troy york voicemails wow overwhelmingly
no right now uh switching to yes
the eyes have it only a little bit right
now
yesterday by a two to one margin the yes
vote won
not quite getting that two-thirds
support today with 134 votes so far
the question is i have a few troy york
voicemails should i play them
67 percent yesterday roughly said play
them
only 58 today saying play them 284 votes
so far
wow people people more aggressively
voting today
in the meantime i'll answer other
questions will biden get money out of
politics
no he will not they need to ask melvin
if he shorted
xrt to cover gme
and if they are still short xrt if they
are they have been lying
publicly and in their testimony whoa
sorry about that all right we'll let
this go
um we'll let this go a little more the
nose making a run for it
on troy york voicemails today yesterday
the nose only had about a third and
today they have 46 percent right now
we maybe we'll let it go to the first
500 votes or so i don't know
some people demanding the vote be
stopped
406 votes 54 say play the voicemails
46 percent say do not do not play the
voicemails
420 430 440
it does look like the yeses still have
it and are in control
although not by much
now down to only 53 percent the slimmest
of margins
this may go into a runoff i mean it's
only two options so i guess the runoff
would be
the same i don't know
459 i think i'm calling it i mean the
vote has slowed down enough that i
believe i am calling it
yeah 474. all right that's a that's a
yes let's take a listen to a couple troy
york voicemails my feeling is that at
some point soon
the nose will have it but for today
let's listen hey
yeah this is wally jackson uh
i was watching your uh
joe joe bike town hall and uh
what's funny is i didn't do the joe
biden town hall just wondering why you
say nothing about how
this man he's so obviously uh
suffering from dementia he has trouble
finishing
sentences he stops he pauses he's having
trouble thinking
have you have you seen trump speak uh he
hesitates as he talks he
he gets confused uh i recall that
you uh attacked president trump
uh for some of this mannerism and now
that you choose to ignore him and joe
biden i mean
this man clearly is so old and senile
he's
unfit i don't think he should even like
finish biden thinks before he talks and
troy york doesn't like it so that's one
troy york voicemail here's another one
no pacman you lie in a desperate attempt
to plague to the chinese and
russian and the foreign energy sectors
who wish to take advantage of our
destruction with their fossil fuels what
by the corrupt democrat party and their
massive regulations
against america being energy independent
all right i'm gonna have to get away
from it from because someone someone's
just continually calling the voicemail
line
so anyway these troy york voicemails are
getting really boring so this may be the
end of the troy york stuff
okay next i am going to adjudicate a few
unban requests on twitch twitch has a
mechanism if you want to be unbanned you
can request it
yesterday someone requested i get a
gavel for when i adjudicate these
and someone offered to make a 50
donation if i get a squeaky gavel so i
ordered one
i'll have it for next week and i will be
able to use a squeaky gavel when i
adjudicate these
let's start with a user who
has sent 15 messages you guys can help
me adjudicate
this guy is selling us all down the
river i remember when david used to
stand up against the democrats now he
would
never i guess he doesn't read messages
unless you pay him
that will never happen if you ignore
chat 24 7.
what don't you fall in line and agree
with that biden does
i'm guessing nothing david used to be
with the people and now he's just a
shill you should feel shame for being
white
david is a full-blown idiot now then
they were banned
their unbanned request is fu for
supporting this shill
all right so that's gonna be perma that
one's denied
next one trump 2024 trump 2024
trump 2024 banned
their unban request is censorship f you
david pakman is wrong what with america
that's going to be permaban denied
the gavel of justice has struck next
unbanned request here is their messages
that got them banned
biden admin vetting questions from the
press
lmao they are literally doing nothing
that trump admin wasn't already doing
what was false and then they were banned
i don't know about this one their
unbanned request is what a weak
moderator hey that was false i say
and then i get banned i'm gonna unban
this person is an idiot but i don't
believe they deserve to be banned so
that one i'm adjudicating as
unban and then just one other one a user
says why is trump perma banned on
twitter the election is over
stop the cancel culture sitting
presidents are above terms of service
either way should not be permanent
january 5 you mean the day of the senate
elections
the lib's bad faith takes kill me
they were banned they said i'm
conservative but banning public
discourse is not helpful
yeah i'm gonna unban this person i don't
uh i don't think they need to be banned
for that definitely an unban
as you guys can see i am very very
flexible with these
that was a weak ban i agree and
sometimes bans are necessary as timeouts
and that's okay but that's an unban
that's definitely an unban as you know
we
we really are only keeping out the most
toxic
of of folks so those are two two permas
and two unbans today and soon i will
have a gavel
for when we uh for when we adjudicate
these so that's coming very soon
david what are your thoughts on chris
hedge's idea that all the delusion and
conspiracy we're seeing is due to
cultural despair and societal trauma i
don't know i haven't i haven't seen his
uh
explanation all right it looks like this
is starting your camera is on
and if you choose to attend a different
remote proceeding please turn your
camera off
today we will make an exception and
allow members from texas
to participate without their video
function
if they are experiencing power outages
that prevent them
from having their videos working if
members wish
to be recognized during the hearing
please
identify yourself by name to facilitate
recognition
i would also ask that members be patient
as the chair proceeds given the nature
of conducting
community committee business virtually
all right so this hearing
is entitled game stopped
who wins and loses when short sellers
social media and retail investors
collide it's already good
i'll recognize myself for three minutes
to give an opening statement good
afternoon
everyone this hearing will be first in a
series of hearings
by the committee to examine the recent
market volatility
involving gamestop so i'm going to step
in just a little bit we we really want
to get to the the questioning is what
people are here for and we're only
partially through with with our business
so
we're going to watch this hearing and
the questions and i already got some
messages from people asking about the
the mars rover landing scheduled for
about two hours from now my goal is to
cover that in two hours and i already
have a stream ready to go
i am very excited about this really
really really excited so
we're hopefully going to get to that in
a couple of hours but for now we are we
are focusing on the robin hood
game stunk hearings and those are going
to be
really really exciting um we will the
stream will
it may be a long stream today the more
the more members we have the more the
stream will go on that's that's the
unfortunate reality
um other other questions coming in give
us more
of that beautiful rio platense you
succulent little zook
oh my god is flan from a box with powder
insulting to you
absolutely the other day i even i got
a flan for takeout from a restaurant it
was a custard
these people were misrepresenting flan
they were giving me they gave me a
custard as if i'm from argentina you
think i'm not gonna know what a flan is
okay anyway uh yes it's very very
insulting and stephen robbins
says d-man legendary hair day keep up
the good work yes
absolutely would i ever have orally
taints
back on for a laugh maybe i'm kind of
over her at this point
i'm kind of over her flan should have
only three ingredients argentinian flan
sugar eggs and milk that's it but at the
bottom you need to get the caramel
um yeah that's that's the reality all
right let's get in here this is getting
going we will we're soon going to start
hearing uh
that testimony system is rigged against
them has been reinforced
others have noted that they're winners
and they are losers
in every trade in our financial markets
our role as a financial services
committee
is to ensure fairness in our financial
markets and system robust protections
for investors and accountability for
wall street today
we will hear firsthand from the
witnesses regarding these events
the hearing will be an opportunity for
this committee to get the facts
about the role each of the entities of
the witnesses represent
played in the events we are examining
today
now i recognize the ranking member of
the committee
the gentleman from north carolina mr
mchenry for five minutes
well uh thank you madam chair and um let
me just begin by saying
i believe americans are far more
sophisticated informed and capable
than people in dc give them credit for
when i called for this hearing last
month i wanted this to be a fact-finding
mission we have speculation we have
headlines and finger-pointing
but we don't have the facts we need
facts
not just the salacious bits or nasty
comments on reddit
and look there's plenty of that we need
the facts today
it's already good some on the left are
already floating new
restrictions or things
the past few weeks it's already
brilliant average everyday investors are
pretty darn sophisticated there is
wisdom
to the crowd so let's zoom out on that
idea
just for a moment the gamestop story
represents a
larger truth a fundamental change
is happening like never before
everyday investors can communicate
access more information
and work collectively to move markets
all in real time
technology is fueling this revolution
congress cannot put technology back in
the box
gamestop is the culmination of years of
pinup frustration
that frustration so we're five minutes
in we've had doji coin as meme number
one
and also a skype call infinity loop
where it's off to a flying start
to pay off their student debt uh from
the gamestop
trade or conversely every story is
somebody who lost money
there were stories of those who said
they were investing in
protests in protest
they would gladly risk losing money just
to prove
a point and now and while
no one should ever risk investing money
that they cannot afford to lose
let's tell the truth of why someone
would do something like that
the sad truth is the k-shaped economy is
nothing new in our capital markets
because the structural core of our
regulations
literally enshrined in
equity policies like the credit investor
definition
blatantly pick winners and losers if
you're wealthy you're good to go
and if you're not you're deemed too dumb
to be trusted with your own money
so a privileged few get to invest
alongside
ivy league endowments getting early
access and private markets to the
greatest returns
of the last two generations
but not so fast for the every average
everyday investor
in the eyes of our government you need
to be protected protected from your own
decisions protected from your own money
protected for more opportunities
so you're left with a savings account
which pays no interest and if
you need more money than that well we
created a world where it's easier to go
buy a lottery ticket than it is to
invest in the next google
is it any wonder why the unhealthy
dynamics of gamestop happened
it's time we get serious about equity
and this is the epitome of faux
right-wing populism
we should live in a world where the
construction worker
or uber driver trading on robin hood
has the same access to equity chairs
and robin hood itself as a white collar
employees who work there
same goes for reddit and reddit users by
the way
both contributed to it to its success
why can't both
share in its future success imagine if
every reddit user was a part owner of
reddit that would be an interesting
concept
more and more in the 1980s massachusetts
and state regulators barred citizens
from investing what the wall street
journal called
the latest in a cascade of stocks of
high technology companies
that occurred that year what ipo is too
risky in the eyes of the government
apple so instead of shutting the
american
public out through new regulations new
forms of taxation or
so-called protections let's use this
opportunity instead
to side with them so i'll begin where i
started
this is crazy americans are far more
sophisticated
informed and capable than folks in d.c
give them credit for and it's time our
securities laws
treat them that way i look forward to
the hearing and i yield back
okay thank you so very much uh i'm so
pleased
uh that you are cooperating today and
you are eager to join with us
when we call for this committee so i
want to welcome today's
distinguished witnesses to the committee
mr vallad tenet is the chief executive
here we go
of robin hood markets incorporated a
company with a trading act
that after increased trading activity in
gamestop
and certain other stocks restricted
trading
of those stocks for a period of time mr
kenneth
c griffin is a chief executive officer
of citadel
llc a fund which is one of robinhood's
main customers
and sources of revenue which also
provided financial support
to melvin capital management lp when
melvin faced significant losses
over gamestop and other trades gabriel
is the chief executive officer of
melbourne capital management lp
which held a significant start position
in
style reddit ruser user crew mungus
will be joining us to explain certain
memes
they made huffman is the chief executive
officer
co-founder of reddit a social media
platform
which is home to the sub reddit wall
street best
where investors discuss trading and
where a large number of members discuss
the purchase
of gamestop and other stocks which
experience volatility
mr keith gill is a retail investor
who posted i don't know why listening to
these folks talk about
like internet culture i it's just one of
the funniest things
god is a director of financial
regulation studies at the cato institute
without objection your written
statements will be made part of the
record
each of you will have five minutes to
celebrate
it was my i believe that there are only
three minutes of democratic opening
statements
uh with the idea that the subcommittee
chair on the democratic side would be
called as well
that's what i was told by your staff
well thank you very much um if uh
that is the order that has been
organized
i will cease my introductions and i will
call on you mr sherman
uh to please go ahead and uh make an
opening statement thank you thank you so
much
back in the day the law school professor
would create an exam
where he'd weave together a story that
would exemplify
each of the issues in that area of the
law
but never did the professor do it as
good a job as the gamestop
saga which identifies most of the issues
facing our capital markets
short selling could there be limits or
required additional disclosures
what do we do with market participants
whether they be on reddit or in on wall
street
who are shorting a stock or buying a
stock for the purpose of influencing its
price
what is this payment for order flow
model
and what does it mean when some
participants get best execution
and some get enhanced best execution
in price enhanced best execution
and all all traders being treated fairly
and
is payment for order flow free to the
consumer
we need to look at the plumbing where it
takes two days to settle a transaction
but also why is it the broker's capital
rather than the customer's capital that
is posted
during the two-day period and finally we
need to look at the gamification and
glorification
of high-frequency uh trading i thank uh
the chairwoman for
uh the time and i hope uh that uh
in the months to come we have several
hearings to explore these issues
and that we're able to pass legislation
this year to deal with each of them
and i yield that thanks to rin
somerville for the website membership
thanks
chairman of the subcommittee of
oversight and investigations
the gentleman from texas mr green for
one minute
thank you very much madam chair i
greatly appreciate the opportunity to
express some concerns that i have it is
a fact that citadel
securities has paid over a hundred
million dollars
in penalties and my concern is this
it deals with whether we can allow a
market makers profit
from misleading clients and improperly
trading ahead of clients
to become something as simple as
honestly can't they
get everybody a headset and just say
plug this thing in and we would that
would deal with
90 of the audio problems they have
i'm concerned and my hope is that we'll
get some additional intelligence on
how these punishments have impacted
the rewards that have been received i
you're back
thank you very much and i will go back
to
the introduction of our witnesses i left
off with jennifer's cup
uh director of financial regulation
studies
at the cato institute without objection
your written statements will be made
part of the record each of you will have
five minutes
to summarize your testimony you should
be able to see a timer
on your screen that will indicate how
much time you have left
and a time will go off at the end of
your time
i would ask you to be mindful of the
timer
and quickly wrap up your testimony if
you hear the chime
now before we begin with your oral
testimonies
i would like to swear in the
witnesses i will call each of your names
individually to respond would you please
raise your hands
do you sound oh my god to affirm that
the testimony
you will give for this committee in the
matters
now under consideration will be the
truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you god
mr chanel are you mr griffin
i do mr plotkin
mr blacken
i was muted i apologize i do thank you
mr huffman
mr gayle
they do thank you very much let the
records show
that all of the witnesses answered in
the affirmative
we will now begin with their oral
testimonies dear
god you are recognized for five minutes
to present
your oral testimony chairwoman waters
ranking member mchenry members of the
committee
my name is vlad oh it's this guy
executive officer
and co-founder of robinhood thank you
for the invitation
to speak about robin hood and the
millions of people we serve
almost eight years ago beijiu bot and i
founded robinhood
we believe then as we do now that the
financial system should be built to work
for everyone
not just a select few we dreamed of
making investing more accessible
especially for people without a lot of
money
the stock market is a powerful wealth
creator but
uh i would like you to use your limited
time to talk directly to
what happened january 28th and your
involvement in certainly
madam chair madam chair the witness has
the opportunity to
to to give their own testimony excuse me
for your question oh this is you and i
recognize uh
mr uh
please go right mister mister you're not
recognized
mr mchenry yes of course
we created robin hood to economically
empower all americans by opening
financial markets
to them i was born in bulgaria a country
with a financial system
that was on the verge of collapse at the
age of five i
immigrated with my family to america in
search of a better life
i have benefited from all america has to
offer
and robinhood's mission to democratize
finance for all
has a very special significance for me
robin with platform allows people from
all backgrounds to invest
with no account minimums and zero
commissions
contrary to some very misleading and
highly uninformed reports
we see evidence that most of our
customers are investing for the long
term
with features like fractional shares
dividend reinvestment
recurring investments our customers can
start with small amounts
and grow their investments in blue chip
stocks and etfs over time
we've always recognized the
responsibility that comes with helping
people invest
we'll continue to enhance our
educational platform to help customers
no matter
where they are in their financial
journey hundreds of free educational
resources
are available to everyone on our learn
website right now
while markets fluctuate this tells me
our business model is working yeah mike
myers definitely should play this guy on
snl that's a good idea
for his assets on robin hood exceeds the
net amount of money
they have deposited with us by over 35
billion dollars
this this tells me our business model is
working for everyday americans
the robin hood community many people say
that robinhood has helped them to pay
car loans
reduce student loan debt meet daily
bills
save for the future and we're proud to
serve them
you've invited me today to discuss the
events of last month and i welcome this
opportunity
in late january many brokerage firms saw
a massive increase in trading activity
in a handful of stocks
prices were moving dramatically day to
day even hour to hour
one specific day january 28th proved to
be a completely
unprecedented event the spike in trading
activity and volatility
meant that robin hood securities our
clearing broker
had to hold the line and post additional
firm capital
as collateral to support our
clearinghouse deposit it's interesting
that they've taken over the phrase hold
the line now too
the requirement was 10 times more than
on january 25th
as a result robin hood securities along
with many other
someone's just clapping the erasers in
the background i mean it's just a
congressional hearing right
we began allowing limited buys of these
securities the following
day and we have since lifted the
restrictions entirely
there are two points i want to make
clear about these temporary restrictions
first robinhood securities put the
restrictions in place in an effort to
meet
increased regulatory deposit
requirements not to help hedge funds
we don't answer to hedge funds we serve
the millions of small investors who use
our platform every day to invest
second robinhood immediately secured
additional funds
all together through capital raising and
other measures
we've increased our liquidity by more
than three billion dollars
to cushion ourselves against increased
collateral requirements
and related market stress in the future
despite the unprecedented market
conditions in january
at the end of the day what happened is
unacceptable to us
to our customers i'm sorry and i
apologize
please know that we are doing everything
we can to make sure this
won't happen but wait if they did
everything right what's he apologizing
one more thing
the existing two-day period to settle
trades exposes investors
and the industry to unnecessary risk
there is
no reason why the greatest financial
system in the world cannot settle trades
in real time
i believe we can and should act now to
deploy
our intellectual capital and our
engineering resources
to move to real-time settlement together
we can solve this
before i close i want to sincerely thank
the millions of customers who continue
to use robinhood
to access the markets every day we are
grateful
and committed to you members of the
committee i appreciate the opportunity
to answer your questions
all right mr griffith you are now
recognized for five minutes
to present your oral testimony
ranking member mchenry distinguished
members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today on the recent market events
the u.s capital markets are the envy of
the world our nation's ability to
allocate capital to its best and highest
use
creates jobs drives innovation and fuels
our economy
america's retail investors play an
important role in our capital markets
according to gallup about 55 percent of
americans own stock
right now so as as they do the
introductions we'll we'll get
we're really all here for the questions
but this is already a pretty epic
hearing technical issues plaguing them
and confusion about procedure and
you know everything it's all very weird
this is going to go on for some
period of time in about an hour and 50
minutes coverage will start of nasa's
mars rover landing i'm really excited
about it and we're planning to cover
that as well
so we have a lot of interesting things
ahead of us today i'm glad that
everybody
is here and watching i see a lot of
people
um uh sending super chats and sending a
lot of messages and the questioning is
going to start very very soon
i do want to say thanks to dan murphy as
well as christopher hendrickson
both of them signed up at joinpakman.com
and i
absolutely love that i really do
appreciate your support um
and uh yes we we are here for the game
stopped
hearings and i am i am looking for the
full list of folks who will be asking
questions i believe aoc will i look
forward to seeing aoc
ask questions to that vlad guy that
should be pretty compelling
um and we're going to be standing by for
those questions momentarily
colleges hospitals foundations and
research
institutions in 2002 my partners and i
found incidental securities
today citadel securities is one of the
world's prominent market makers
we've been a leader in using technology
to transform our markets
particularly for retail investors
citadel securities invest hundreds of
millions of dollars each year
to serve the needs of our customers in
the last week of january
the importance of this investment was on
full display
during the period of frenzied retailed
equities trading
citadel securities was able to provide
continuous liquidity
every minute of every trading these are
like advertisements
when others were unable
citadel securities was there on
wednesday
january 27th we executed
seven 7.4 billion
shares on behalf of retail investors
to put this into perspective on that day
civil securities
executed more shares for retail
investors
than the entire average daily volume of
the entire
u.s equities market he was also drinking
bud light lime
while uh doing the entire thing bud
light lime refreshing
citrusy and that flavor you've known to
come and love
from bud liver in all market conditions
and underscores the critical importance
of our resilient
and stable systems i
could not be more proud of our team
at citadel securities my colleagues who
were committed
to ensuring that the interest of
america's retail investors
were served during this extraordinary
period
once again today
and i look forward to answering your
questions
thank you mr griffin mr plotkin you are
now recognized for five minutes
to present your oral testimony
chairwoman waters ranking member mchenry
members of the committee
i would like to thank you for this
opportunity to share melvin capital's
perspective on the recent trading
activity in gamestop
i am the founder and chief investment
officer of melbourne capital i am
humbled by these unprecedented events
my investors and also many investors on
all sides have experienced losses
i am here today to share my own personal
experience
and to be helpful in this conversation i
understand that part of the focus of
this hearing is the decision of stock
trading platforms to limit trading and
gamestop
i want to make clear at the outset that
melvin capital played absolutely no role
in those trading platform decisions in
fact melvin closed out all of its
positions in game stop
days before the platforms put those
limitations in place
like you we learned about those limits
from news reports
i also want to make clear at the outset
that contrary to many reports
melvin capital was not bailed out in the
midst of these events
citadel proactively reached out to
become a new investor
similar to the investments others make
in our funds it was an opportunity for
citadel to buy low
and earn returns for its investors if
and when our fund's value went up
to be sure melvin was managing through a
difficult time but we always had margin
access
and we were not seeking a cash infusion
i'm here testifying today far removed
from my background
i grew up in a middle-class family in
portland maine i went to a public high
school
we are going to temporarily step away
from this hearing on gamestop stock
trading to keep our over 40-year
commitment to live coverage of congress
uh-oh continue watching online at
c-span.org
u.s house holding a brief pro-formation
we are online back to the hearing
after this let's see if they go back
no they don't all right we'll switch
over here we do this after extensive
research sometimes literally for years
when our research convinces us that a
company will grow
relative to expectations we make a
long-term investment
when our research suggests a company
will not live up to expectations
and its stock price is overvalued we
might short a stock
like with our long positions our
practice is to short a stock for the
long term
after extensive research we also short
stocks because when the markets go down
we're going to get away from this and go
to the 18th hole where uh
uh greg norman is about to putt for
birdie in addition
it's very important to understand that
absolutely none of melvin's short
positions are part of any effort to
artificially depress or manipulate down
with the price of a stock
nothing about our short possession
prevents a company from achieving its
objectives
it is just melvin's view about whether
it will
specific to gamestop we had a research
supported view well before the recent
events
in fact we have been short gamestop
since melvin's inception
six years earlier because we believed
and still believed that its business
model
selling new and used video games in
physical stores
is being overtaken by digital downloads
through the internet
and that trend only accelerated in 2020
when because of the pandemic people were
downloading video games at home
as a result the gaming industry had its
best year ever but gamestop had
significant losses
in january 2021 so he's defending the
short posts
about melbourne's specific investments
they took information contained in our
sec filings and encouraged others to
trade in the opposite direction
many of these posts were laced with
anti-semitic slurs directed at me and
others
that's true the post said things like
it's very clear we need a second
holocaust the jews can't keep getting
away with this
other sense similarly profane and racist
text message that the the
the amount listen when this when i heard
this guy's name gabriel plotkin
i was worried we were even going to
start seeing anti-semitic comments
because this
that is a that is a virus that is
everywhere right now
the unfortunate part of this episode is
that ordinary investors who were
convinced by a misleading frenzy
to buy gamestop at 100 200 or even 483
dollars have now lost significant
amounts
when this frenzy began melvin started
closing out its position
at gamestop at a loss not because our
investment thesis had changed but
because something unprecedented was
happening
we also reduced many other melbourne
positions at significant losses
both long and short that were the
subject of similar posts i'm personally
humbled
by what happened in january investors in
melbourne suffered significant losses
it is now our job to earn it back and
while i do not think that anyone could
have anticipated these events
i have learned much from them and i am
taking steps to protect our investors
from anything like this happening in the
future
i look forward to answering your
questions
okay
thank you mr plotkin mr huffman you are
now recognized for five minutes
to present your oral testimony
thank you i am chairwoman mr ranking
member
honorable members of the committee my
name is steve huffman
i am the co-founder and ceo of reddit
and i'm pleased to talk with you today
about how reddit works
and what we have seen on our site he's
going to explain how reddit works to
maxine waters reddit's mission is to
bring community and belonging to
everyone in the world
what started in 2005 as a single
community has since evolved into a vast
network of many thousands of communities
as a show of good faith i will be
gifting all members of congress on this
committee
reddit gold for two months culture to
support
for example our unemployment community
has become a source of support for
hundreds of thousands of americans
who have turned to reddit after losing
their jobs during the pandemic
our communities are created and run by
our users because of this
we describe reddit as the most human
place on the internet though we are
small compared to the largest platforms
our communities provide an online home
for millions of people every day
i'd like to share a bit about how
content moderation on reddit works
reddit's moderation system starts with
our content policy the platform-wide
rules which all communities must follow
among other things these rules prohibit
hate harassment
bullying and illegal activity on reddit
and they are enforced by reddit's
anti-evil team which is composed of
engineers
data scientists and other specialists
this team also ensures the integrity of
the site and we have continuously honed
our methods to stay ahead of bad actors
to protect reddit from manipulation
spam and other threats this team
searched high and low for the specific
comment mentioned in the previous
testimony or anything like it
i would love for him to give us the
background on his reddit username spez
and what the story is with that
such speeches not tolerated on reddit
and we will of course investigate any
further claims of this nature
centralized moderation is common but
reddit additionally uses a governance
structure akin to a federal democracy
where the aforementioned policies and
teams represent the federal government
and the communities themselves represent
states
all communities or subreddits are
created by users that we call moderators
they set the community's rules which may
be as strict as they like as long as
they are not in conflict with the
platform-wide policies
and they have a variety of tools of
enforcing these rules independently
moderators are not paid employees but
rather users who are passionate about
their communities
isn't that the truth the context and
judgment to make decisions no algorithm
could
the members of each community contribute
both the content itself
and the ranking of it by voting up or
down on any post or comment
unlike other platforms where submission
has a built-in audience through the
author's follower account
every piece of content on reddit no
matter how famous the author
starts at zero and has to earn its
visibility
through their votes the community itself
enforces not just the explicit rules of
their
community but also the unwritten rules
that define their culture
this layered approach has helped our
users create the most authentic
communities
online the specific community we'd like
to talk about today is wall street vets
it's important to understand that wall
street bets is one of many finance and
investing related communities on reddit
this particular community specializes in
higher risk higher reward investments
than what you specialize in
more conservative financial communities
i love that such names as personal
finance
investing in financial independence
i will stress that wall street vets is
first and foremost a real community
the self-deprecating jokes the memes the
crass at times language
all reflect this if you spend any time
on wall street bets you'll find a
significant
depth to this community exhibited by the
affection its members show one another
they are just as quick to support a
fellow member after a big loss
as they are to celebrate after a big
game
a few weeks ago we saw the power of
community in general and of this
community in particular when the traders
of wall street bets
banded together at first to seize an
investment opportunity not usually
accessible to retail investors
but later more broadly to defend all
retail investors against the criticism
of the financial establishment
with the increase in attention wall
street bets unsurprisingly faced the
surge in traffic and new users
at reddit our first duty in these
situations is to our communities and our
role in this moment was to keep wall
street bets online
working around the clock we scaled our
infrastructure made technology changes
to help this community withstand the
onslaught of traffic
and we acted as diplomats to help
resolve conflict within wall street vets
leadership
we have since analyzed activity in wall
street in wall street bets to determine
whether bots
foreign agents or other bad actors
played a significant role
they have not in every metric we checked
the activity in wall street bets was
well within normal parameters and its
moderation tools are working as expected
we will of course cooperate with valid
legal requests from federal and state
regulators
that said we do believe that this
community was well within the bounds of
our own policies
to conclude i would like to reiterate
why it is important to protect online
communities like wall street bats
wall street bets may look sophomoric or
chaotic from the outside
but the fact that we're here today means
they've managed to raise important
issues about fairness and opportunity in
our financial system
i'm proud to use reddit to do so thank
you and i look forward to your questions
very strong real quick thank you to
jeeves murphy
as well as dennis laurie denise laurie
for signing up at joinedpakman.com
they'll continue here
thank you very much mr huffman mr gill
you are now recognized
for five minutes to present your oral
testimony
thank you chairwoman waters ranking
member mchenry
members of the committee i am happy to
discuss with the committee
my purchases of gamestop shares and my
discussions of their fair value
oh this is the best it is true that my
investment in that company
multiplied in value many times
for that i feel enormously fortunate
i also believe the current price of the
shares demonstrates
that i've been right about the company a
few things i am not
i'm not a cat i am not an institutional
investor
am i a hedge fund i do not have clients
and i do not
personalize investment advice for fees
or commissions
i'm just an individual whose investment
in gamestop and posts on social media
were based upon my own research oh this
is the best
i grew up in brockton massachusetts my
family was not wealthy
this guy's actually a co-worker of a
friend of mine registered nurse
or he was until he got all that money
and the first in my family to earn a
four-year college degree
when i graduated from stonehill college
in 2009
that was not a good time to be looking
for a job from 2010 to 2017
i worked a few startup companies but
there were significant periods when i
was unemployed
i took an interest in the stock market
and even though i had very little money
i used those times to educate myself and
learn more about investing
2019 after nearly two years unemployed
i accepted a marketing and financial
education job at massmutual
my wife caroline and i were thrilled
that i had an income
and benefits my job was to help develop
financial education classes that
advisors could present
to i was not prospective stock broker
or a financial advisor i did not talk to
clients
and i did not recommend stocks for them
to buy
before and after i joined mass mutual i
studied and followed stocks
one of those was gamestop early june of
2019
the price of gamestop stock declined
below what i thought was its fair value
i invested in gamestop in 2019 and 2020
because
as i studied the company i became more
and more confident in my analysis
two important factors based entirely on
publicly available information
gave me confidence that gamestop was
undervalued
first the market was underestimating the
prospects of gamestop's legacy business
and overestimating the likelihood of
bankruptcy
i grew up playing video games and
shopping at gamestop and i plan to
continue shopping there
gamestop stores still provide real value
to consumers
and reliable revenue for gamestop second
i believe that gamestop has the
potential to reinvent itself as the
ultimate destination
for gamers within the rapidly growing
200 billion dollar gaming industry
gamestop has a unique opportunity to
pivot toward a technology driven
business
by embracing the digital economy
gamestop may be able to find new revenue
streams it's almost like an advisor to
games
it's business i'm hardly the only person
who has advocated these points
when i wrote and spoke about gamestop
and social media with other individual
investors
our conversations were no different from
people in a bar
or in a golf course or at home talking
or arguing about a stock
hedge funds and other wall street firms
have teams of analysts
working together to compile research and
analyze shares of companies
individual investors do not have those
resources
social media platforms like reddit
youtube and twitter
are leveling the playing field the idea
that i use social media to promote
gamestop stock
to unwitting investors and influence the
market is preposterous
my post did not cause the movement of
billions of dollars into gamestop shares
it is tragic that some people lost money
and my heart goes out to them
but what happened in january just
demonstrates again that i made a lot of
public securities is extremely risky
as i said earlier i consider myself and
my family fortunate with our investment
when the stock price broke 20 in
december i knew my investment was a
success
i was so happy to visit my family in
brockton for the holidays
the money will go such a long way for us
we had an incredibly difficult 2020.
most difficult was the tragic and
unexpected loss of my sister sarah in
june
i am grateful to be in a position to
give back to and support my family
as for what happened in january others
will have to explain it
it's alarming how little we know about
the inner workings of the market
and i am thankful that this committee is
examining what happened
i also want to say that i support retail
investors right to invest in what they
want
when they want i support the right of
individuals to send a message based on
how they invest
it does sound like there's a cash
register dinging in the background
i'm as bullish as i've ever been at a
potential turnaround for gamestop
and i remain invested in the company
thank you
cheers everyone thank you mr gill
ms trump you are now recognized for five
minutes to present your oral testimony
what a day chairwoman waters
ranking member mchenry and distinguished
members of the committee on financial
services
my name is jennifer schulp and i am the
director of financial regulation studies
at the cato institute's center for
monetary and financial alternatives
thank you for the opportunity to take
part in today's hearing
before addressing the gamestop
phenomenon specifically
i'd like to talk about the participation
of retail
or individual i actually have no idea
why she's here cato institute is a right
wing think tank i just don't know what
her role is in this
but the recent upward trend accelerated
sharply during the pandemic
most point to zero commission trading
but several other factors also likely
attracted retail investors
including fractional share trading low
account minimums
and easy app-based platforms more time
at home during the pandemic
probably even played a role right back i
got to deliver it in our equities
markets
is important the fact that retail
investors behave differently from
institutional ones
and differently from each other can be
particularly valuable in times of market
stress
in fact individual investors may have
helped stabilize the market in march
2020.
importantly investing in the stock
market also provides a path to wealth
for individual investors but stock
ownership
traditionally has been skewed towards
the already wealthy
and it is highly correlated with race
education
and age retail investors making up this
new surge are different
recent research by the finra investor
education foundation
and newark at the university of chicago
found that investors who opened accounts
for the first time in
2020 were younger had lower incomes
and were more racially diverse these new
investors
also held lower account balances this
may pretend
as one of the researchers noted quote a
shift
towards more equitable investment
participation
these new opportunities for individuals
to grow their wealth should be welcomed
and expanded
not restricted now i'll turn to gamestop
at the outset i will note that it is
difficult to analyze the impact of the
trading in gamestop and other stocks
because many facts are unknown
but some things seem clear importantly
the temporary volatility in these stocks
did not present a systemic risk to
market function
as the treasury department recognized
the market's
core infrastructure was resilient during
high volatility
and heavy trading volume this is not
surprising
despite the huge trading volume and
rapid increase in value
only a small part of the market was
affected and
spillover effects on the wider market
were mild and short-lived
the fact that gamestop traded
temporarily and perhaps still trades
above
fair estimates of the company's value is
not
by itself a reason for concern stock
prices move in and out of alignment all
the time
and markets are no strangers to bubbles
if a company is valued by the market
differently than a review of its
fundamentals suggests
it might indicate that the analysis is
missing relevant information about a
company's prospects
or it might indicate that the company's
stock price is due for a correction
the market's mechanisms including the
tool of short selling
generally work well to handle these
circumstances
stepping in to prevent trading whereas
stock price moves contrary to
conventional wisdom
could deprive the market of important
information
information the sec among a host of
others
is reviewing the relevant trading and
conducting a study of the events
the sec will have access to far more
information that has been made publicly
available
and i believe it has the tools necessary
to address
any harmful misconduct that may have
occurred
i cannot opine on whether any regulatory
changes are warranted on this incomplete
record
i tend to believe the answer will be no
in light of the minimal impact on the
markets
it's cato but if regulators learn more
there may
be areas it's weird to have an
anti-regulation spokesperson come on and
be like i think we don't need regulation
like maybe we do maybe we don't but why
ask cato
to the markets thank you and i welcome
any questions that you may have
thank you i now
recognize myself five minutes for
questions
the market volatility surrounding
gamestop
and other securities has highlighted how
many people feel
that the cards are stacked against them
and that market participants
like our witnesses hide the ball mr
taniv
you explained that robin hood restricted
transactions in certain securities
to meet demands coming from your
clearinghouse and yet
on january 28th you represented uh to
the media
that there was no liquidity problem
isn't it true that
being concerned about having enough
capital
uh to meet deposit requirements isn't
that a liquidity problem or could you
just answer yes or no
chairwoman waters i appreciate the
opportunity to address that
yes ago we always felt comfortable with
our liquidity and the additional capital
that robin
i don't have time i just need a yes or
no answer i i stand by my statement
the additional capital we raised wasn't
to meet capital requirements or deposits
this liquidity problem had real
consequences for your customers
but i wonder if they were all that
surprised between december 2019
and december 2020 robin hood customers
experienced
monetary losses due to system outages
customer accounts were reportedly
compromised the firm repeatedly failed
to testify
its best execution obligations and it
misled its customers
regarding its revenue sources it seems
retail investors
often get a bad deal at robin hood mr
tanev
also or while you testify today that
quote
robin hood's customers benefit greatly
from payment for order flow
quote unquote in december 2020 the sec
charged robin hood
for not disclosing that it was getting
uh paid
to send customer trades to citadel
securities
and other market makers and for not
seeking the best terms for its customers
orders
robinhood provided such inferior trade
prices it costs your customers over 34
million
is your testimony after robin hood paid
uh is it your testimony after robin had
paid the sec
65 million to settle those charges
that this conflict of interest is in
your customers best interest
yes or no chairwoman waters first let me
say
regulatory compliance is at the center
of everything that we do
we've made mistakes in the past i'm not
claiming that
everybody's playing a role maxine waters
is reading stuff that clearly she
doesn't really deeply understand in
terms of the issues
and he's reading pre-written answers to
avoid answering yes or no
reason that gentleman can answer yes or
no i'm reclaiming my time
meanwhile mr griffin citadel's role in
this event also raises
significant what a doji coin here
citadel securities
pays robin hood tens of millions of
dollars
to process trades by robin woods
customers
this relationship gives citadel
enterprise key non-public information
as to direction and volume of trades by
retail investors
your firm makes use of private exchanges
called dark pools
and other uh off exchange trading
to trade large sciences without moving
the market against you in fact
at some point last month 50 percent
of all trades occurred in dark pools
or via otc off exchange
trades your business strategy is
designed intentionally
to undermine market transparency and
skim profits from companies
and other investors one problem though
mr griffin is that we don't really know
how central your firm has become to the
capital markets mr griffin
does citadel handle 47 of the u.s
listed retail volume please yes or no
excuse me uh chairman waters what what
percentage i couldn't hear that number
47 so
chairman waters to the best yes
so the odd that's my knowledge we handle
in excess of roughly 40 percent of all
retail volumes thank you very much for
reclaiming my time
mr griffin on january 27 the citadel
executes 7.4 billion shares for retail
investors
which would be more trades than the
average daily
volume of the entire united states
equities market
in 2019 yes or no uh chairman waters
that was my written and oral testimony
thank you very much uh and with that i
now recognize the distinguished ranking
member mr mchenry
for five minutes for questions this is
pretty wacky all right
thank you uh mr uh today i'm going to
come to you first
uh i i just want to get to what happened
on that day in january so let's take a
step back here
you get a call in the middle of the
night according to what i've
heard uh you and interviews say and
based off that conversation with your
compliance team you decided to
halt the buying of game stock stock
uh people were furious um we'll get into
the regulations and the settlement parts
of that uh today
we will get to that but there's
this is what i think needs to be
answered about your decision
why did robin hood restrict the buying
but not the selling
of gamestop why do folks get locked out
on the buy side only
ranking member mchenry i appreciate the
opportunity to address that
but the reason that robin hood
first of all let me say robin hood is
always committed to providing access
it's in our name it's in everything that
we do
the decision to restrict gamestop and
other securities was driven purely by
deposit and collateral requirements
imposed by our clearing houses
so uh buying uh
buying why why
buying securities why pieces are good
selling does not moreover preventing
customers from selling
is a very difficult and painful
experience
where customers are unable to access
their money
so we don't want to impose that type of
experience on our customers
unless we have no other choice and even
though i recognize customers were
very upset and disappointed that we had
to do this
i imagine it would have been
significantly worse if we prevented
customers from selling
okay so let me ask this question is
payment for order flow
legal yes
payment for order flow is
it is this disclosed to those users of
your app yes payment for order flow
is disclosed in multiple places
and moreover order flow enables
commission free trading and that's why
it's become the industry standard model
as other brokerages have replicated our
model and started offering commission
free trading
to their customers as well okay so so to
that
to this greater point of what happened
that day and the model that you're using
uh let's be crystal clear that decision
you made
to restrict the buying but not the
selling of gamestop
was based what was it based on pressure
from anyone
on the witness panel here today
not at all zero pressure from anyone it
was
a collateral depository requirement
decision made by
our robinhood securities president
all right so let me get into this other
question let me get in this question you
want to democratize
uh finance you want to open up
wall street to retail investors you say
that robin hood's mission is to
democratize finance for all
so let's talk about that so yes or no
can a robin hood customer invest in
robin hood the company
robin it's currently a private company
so that that's not possible no
yeah and so you you mean to tell me that
the people that use your platform that
make you a successful company
and i would say directly contribute to
your company's exponential growth and
success
they don't get the same access to equity
shares as a robin hood employee
or your institutional investors is that
correct
currently that is correct yes all right
miss schultz let me
that pivot to you why is that why is why
is it that everyday investors
on the robin hood app uh people that i
would argue contributed to
success does he know how private
companies work like just because i buy
just because i buy stuff at best buy
doesn't automatically give me ownership
those folks that are known as accredited
investors
and to become an accredited investor you
have to have a wealth
meet a wealth test of earning at least
200 000
a year a year or having a net worth of
over a million dollars
the vast majority of people in this
country don't meet that standard
and are unable to invest in most private
companies
okay so let me let me just clear this uh
mr tenef i don't blame you
for for the restriction you put on your
customers not being able to invest in
equity
i'd like to have more opportunity to ask
mr gill his thoughts on this but
let me just say this i don't i don't
fault you for the inequitable
regulatory structure that dc has created
uh but i think we need to clear this up
final thing madam chair i have a uh
uh for the record i'd like to submit a
letter from the dtcc
which is the clearing company uh that
that was not on the panel today
uh and there uh your staff has this
letter
all right thank you all and look forward
to getting to the facts
from uh other members ms maloney
chairwoman waters uh and ranking member
mchenry for convening this harry
i i hope today's hearing sheds light on
how our markets are working
or in many cases are not working for
smaller investors and ways we can fix
that
the events of late january saw
tremendous volatility
and stock prices that were totally
divorced from market fundamentals
the whole enterprise was viewed by some
as a giant
video game trading stocks instead of
properties and monopoly money
but it's not all fun and games because
people can lose their life savings
their hard earned cash and tragically
last summer we know of at least one
suicide
linked to potential trading losses
beyond those possible losses the actions
of robin hood and other trading
platforms
during the gamestop frenzy
caused confusion anger and undermined
investor confidence in the fundamental
fairness
of our capital markets none of this is
healthy for our markets
are good for investors what makes
markets work
fairly is when everyone knows the rules
and that the rules remain consistent and
predictable
and are enforced but because of robin
hood's actions too many customers did
not
get that predictability many retail
investors woke up on january 28
to find that they could no longer buy
and sell
stocks the same way they could the days
prior
and they were being treated differently
than other
market participants who could still buy
and sell those same stocks so
i don't blame them for thinking that
things were stacked against the little
guy
mister tina have you stated in your
testimony they have five minutes she's
been talking for three
securities including gamestop in order
to meet your financial requirements
with your clearing house but when i go
to robin hood's website
and the blog post you initially released
on january 28th
your financial requirements with your
clearinghouse are not mentioned
you only mention market volatility
and when i review the robinhood customer
agreement you don't include specifics on
how and when you may decide to re to
restrict trading
which you did and you don't include
any language or disclosures regarding
your capital requirements
it only includes vague language that
at any time and in its sole discretion
robinhood can restrict trading in other
words you seem to reserve the right to
make up the rules as you go along so i i
have
two questions for you first do you think
you owe
your customers more disclosure and
transparency than you gave them
and second do you believe your lack of
candor
with your customers might have
contributed
to the wild speculation and confusion
that resulted in the aftermath
of your trading restrictions
congresswoman i appreciate the question
um
so to answer the second question
look i'm sorry for what happened
i apologize and i'm not
going to say that robin hood did
everything perfect
and that we haven't made mistakes in the
past but what i commit to
is making sure that we improve from this
we learn from it and we don't make the
same mistakes in the future
and robinhood as an organization will
learn from this
and improve to make sure it doesn't
happen again and
i'll make sure of that well i expect we
will experience
future events with increased volatility
and robinhood's recent
actions appeared arbitrary is
which is why i don't blame customers for
feeling treated unfairly
your your trading restrictions came out
of the blue
and your communication was not clear so
my next question mr tanev
looking forward what operational changes
is robinhood making to
better respond to future market
volatility
to improve transparency with your
customers
and to ensure retail customers don't get
the rug
pulled out from under them at the last
minute
thank you for that question
congresswoman we'll be committing to
reviewing
absolutely everything about this but the
3.4 billion dollars that we raised
i think goes a long way to cushioning
the firm from
future market volatility and other
similar black swan events
and uh i believe that even throughout
this process
we improved our risk management
processes and strengthened them
so that the experience customers had
thank you madam chair and i'd like to
welcome our witnesses for testifying
today to discuss the late january market
volatility that took place along with
what i hope
is a broader discussion on market
functions
and their effect on everyday investors
since i was very first elected i have
advocated for
america's main street investors and
worked
tirelessly to ensure that all americans
especially those low and middle income
favors are giving the investment choice
access and affordability that they
deserve retail investors
are the strength of our stock market
and i have fought throughout my career
for their best interests
in the financial markets and this
hearing today is no different
the advances in financial technology
that we've witnessed in the last decade
have improved
the way that americans and our
businesses perform
financial activities in just the past
year we have seen
retail investors market participation
more than double and i think this
is great i believe in the wisdom
of the retail investor and i will say i
believe in the first amendment too
uh this increase is attributed
uh to robin hood and other trading
brokerages who
are lowering account minimums permitting
fractional share trading and
implementing zero commission
trading it's critical that
congress focus on reducing barriers
reducing
barriers to market participation which
is rarely
uh i rarely want to do let me sadly say
and allowing main street uh americans
access to the financial instruments that
can create long-term investment
savings all of these changes have given
millions of americans the ability to
invest
better for their families and their
future my hope
is that the majority does not use this
hearing as an excuse to once again
add new federal regulatory burdens
to an industry that is already heavily
regulated and that will prevent people
from participating in our capital
markets
imagine thinking the financial industry
is too heavily regulated
being everyday investors with new and
more costly barriers to entry
mr tinnett it appears at the time your
company
did not have enough money to meet the
collateral requirements for that level
of trading by your customers
and your view a were collateral
requirements by
from the dtcc unreasonably high was the
amount of trading
on your platform unforeseeable or
was your company under capitalized given
its risk profile
thank you for the question congresswoman
so uh
this event was a five sigma event
which is a one in 3.5 million event
to put that in context there have only
been tens of thousands of
stock market days in the history of the
u.s stock market
so one in 3.5 million event
basically is unmodelable that said we
can learn from it
and in this particular case our risk
management processes
worked appropriately to keep us in
compliance with all of our defaulted
requirements and collateral requirements
well mr chav i i realize that you are
doing a full
review of your practices and such um
i encourage you to do that and certainly
communication
with your investors is going to be key
to that because you didn't communicate
with them early on
let me just say as a ranking member on
the diversity and inclusion subcommittee
i
am delighted to be speaking with our
witness ms jennifer schult
ranking member mchenry and i have spent
countless hours stressing the importance
of having
qualified women in finance so i'm
pleased to have you here today to lend
your expertise michelle
we now know that it was the daily
collateral demands set by the national
security clearing
uh corporation that were the reason
robin hood had to temporarily restrict
trading
can you briefly explain the purpose of
these capital
requirements and their overall
relationship to ensuring our markets
function in an orderly manner and did
you see any broad failures of market
function
during these events ma'am sure thank you
thank you for the compliment um the
pscc's collateral requirements here
serve the function
to to provide security
for the stock segment process goes
through
so while an investor thinks that what
has happened is they bought a stock on
the day that they
they make a trade it really takes two
days
for the settlement process to clear
during that time the brokerage firm
the dtcc
all right guys um so this is probably
enough for me i'm not gonna lie this is
not exactly going in the direction
because of the technical situation that
allows this to be even remotely
productive
so i am going to cover the mars landing
but i'm going to reset the stream and
and do a different stream title and be
back in about a half hour
and we'll pick up right where we left
off so i want to thank say thanks to
paul misner
or meisner as well as hannah cervantes
every everybody counts all these new
members count we'll pick up the twitch
number as well
uh which is a plus three um and i'm
gonna be back with everybody in about a
half hour it's just impossible to even
follow what's going on the tech is a
disaster they're ranting and raving for
three of their five minutes of questions
so we'll do a clip with highlights from
this
i'm gonna briefly step away we're gonna
reset and be back for the mars landing
in about a half hour which i'm very much
looking forward to